STEVE ARCE I WOULD LIKE TO
APOLOGIZE FOR PLAYING WITH THE
RED HOT CHILI PEPPERS IN THE
EARLIER SEGMENT.
WE WILL NEVER DO THAT AGAIN.
MY HOW THE WORLD HAS CHANGED.
THOUSANDS OF GOOGLE EMPLOYEES
SIGNED A LETTER CHASTISING THEIR
COMPANY FOR WORKING WITH
PENTAGON DRONES SO ONLY BAD GUYS
GET KILLED IN WAR, NOT CIVILIANS
CIVILIANS.
IT COULD CHANGE WAR FOREVER.
THESE EMPLOYEES THINK THAT'S
EVIL.
GO FIGURE.
HOW DOES A COMPANY LIKE GOOGLE
THRIVE?
IT HELPS TO EXIST IN A COUNTRY
WITH THE WORLD'S GREATEST
DEFENSES WHICH ENABLES FREEDOM
TO THRIVE.
IT HELPS THAT OVER HALF A
CENTURY AGO AMERICAN COMPANIES
MADE UP OF YOUNG MEN AND WOMEN
HELPED US WHEN MAXIM WORLD WARS.
WITHOUT THAT, WE WILL BE
SPEAKING GERMAN.
DURING WORLD WAR II, U.S.
INDUSTRIES PRODUCE MORE THAN --
300,000 PLANES, 100,000 TANKS
AND 15 MILLION GUNS.
ALL OF THIS FROM THE HOME FRONT.
HOW IS THE HOME FRONT NOW?
THESE CHILDLIKE GOOGLE HEADS
THINK THEY CAN LIVE FOREVER IN A
SILICONE BUBBLE IMMUNE TO THE
REAL WORLD'S RISK AND
RESPONSIBILITY IS UNAWARE OF THE
SACRIFICES GRANDPARENTS AND
GREAT PARENTS MADE TO ENABLE THE
COMPANY LIFESTYLE.
TERRORISTS REFINE THEIR
TECHNOLOGY AND PLAN THE NEXT
9/11.
THESE KIDS AT GOOGLE THINK THEIR
EXPERTISE SHOULD ONLY BE USED
FOR GETTING DIRECTIONS.
THANK GOD THEY WEREN'T AROUND IN
THE 1940s.
KIMBERLY.
DRONES ARE GOING TO BE USED TO
TARGET BAD GUYS SO YOU HAVE LESS
COLLATERAL DAMAGE.
HOW CAN YOU BE AGAINST THAT?
>> Kimberly: IT DOESN'T MAKE
SENSE.
WHEN YOU LOOK AT THE MEDICAL
IDEOLOGY, ERIC SCHMIDT, RUNNING
GOOGLE.
THE HILLARY CLINTON CAMPAIGN
EVENTS.
ANYWAY, THEY GO THROUGH THIS
WHOLE BACKGROUND CHECKING.
IT'S PRETTY MUCH LOCKSTEP OVER
THERE IN TERMS OF PROGRESSIVE
IDEALS.
THEY THINK IT'S THE RIGHT IDEA
TO BE ON THE RIGHT SIDE OF IT
AND SAY WE ARE AGAINST WAR.
TO HAVE THIS KIND OF POSITION.
THEY DON'T UNDERSTAND WHAT THEY
ARE PROTESTING AGAINST.
THEY ARE PROTESTING AT THE
PENTAGON OR DEPARTMENT OF
DEFENSE, ANYTHING LIKE THAT.
IT IS HELPING YOU BE SAFE.
CYBER SECURITY.
WHY WOULD THEY BE OPPOSED TO IT?
NOT VERY WELL THOUGHT OUT.
>> Greg: KENNEDY, I COULD SEE
THIS IN A WORLD WITHOUT TERROR
AND TOXIC EXISTENTIAL
IDEOLOGIES.
WE ARE IN A DIFFERENT KIND OF
MORE.
IT'S NOT A WAR ON A BATTLEFIELD.
IT'S AROUND AND WAITING FOR THE
OPPORTUNITY.
SHOULD THEY BE ARRESTED?
>> Kennedy: IT'S A LITTLE
AUTHORITARIAN.
I WILL SAY THERE IS MERIT TO
BEING ANTIWAR.
I UNDERSTAND THAT AND I
UNDERSTAND THE DESIRE AND THE
THREAT TO USE TECHNOLOGY FOR
POSITIVE MEANS FOR BRINGING
PEOPLE OUT OF POVERTY, EDUCATING
PEOPLE.
THAT'S ALL WELL AND GOOD.
I DON'T HAVE A PROBLEM WITH
THAT.
I AGREE WITH THEM THAT THE
MARRIAGE OF BIG GOVERNMENT WITH
BIG TECHNOLOGY IS REALLY SCARY.
>> Greg: IN A GOOD WAY?
>> Kennedy: WILL KNOW.
WEAPONS OF WAR AND SURVEILLANCE
COMBINED.
ESSENTIALLY WE ARE POWERLESS.
THE SECOND AMENDMENT IS
IMPORTANT BECAUSE PEOPLE CAN
DEFEND THEMSELVES.
>> Greg: WITH DRONES.
YOU COULD DEFEND YOURSELF WITH
DRONE.
>> Kennedy: DOES EVERYBODY GET
AN ARMED DRONE?
CAN WE TARGET PEOPLE WITH
PRECISION?
MY QUESTION IS NOT HOW CAN THIS
BE USED, WHAT'S THE INTENTION.
THE INTENTION IS ALMOST ALWAYS
GOOD.
IT IS HOW CAN IT BE MISUSED?
HOW CAN IT BE MISUSED?
>> Greg: YOU CAN ARGUE THAT
WITH EVERY TECHNOLOGY.
>> Kennedy: I POSE THE
QUESTION, WHAT GOVERNMENT
FUNCTIONS ARE ACCEPTABLE?
>> Greg: EXCELLENT QUESTION.
JASON, PERHAPS YOU COULD ANSWER
IT.
DON'T MENTION SOCCER.
>> Jason: THESE GOOGLE PEOPLE
ARE SHOWING A DEGREE OF
IMMATURITY.
IT'S LOOKING AT THE
NATIONAL GUARD, THE MEN AND
WOMEN WHO SERVE OUR NATION, THEY
DON'T HAVE A SPECIFIC POLITICAL
IDEOLOGY.
LOOK AT SOME NAUGHTY KID AT
GOOGLE WHO IS TRYING TO SAY OUR
TECHNOLOGY IS BETTER THAN THAT.
WE SHOULDN'T ALLOW YOU TO HAVE
IT.
I BELIEVE IN PEACE THROUGH
STRENGTH.
THE REASON THE UNITED STATES IS
THE GREATEST COUNTRY ON THE
PLANET IS BECAUSE WE'VE HAD HARD
PEOPLE DO DIFFICULT THINGS AND
THERE'S A PRICE TO FREEDOM.
THEY DON'T WANT TO PARTICIPATE
IN THAT?
THEY DON'T WANT TO USE THEIR
EXPERTISE TO KEEP US THE
GREATEST COUNTRY ON THE PLANET?
THAT IS SO WRONG.
>> Juan: I DON'T UNDERSTAND.
THE YOUNG PEOPLE, I DON'T KNOW
IF THEY ARE YOUNG, THEY COULD BE
ERIC SCHMITZ AGE.
PEOPLE AT GOOGLE ARE SAYING YOU
CAN'T OUTSOURCE RESPONSIBILITY
FOR YOUR TECHNOLOGY.
WHAT KENNEDY SAYS IS RIGHT.
WHAT HAPPENS AND PEOPLE START
USING THIS FOR EVIL PURPOSES AND
YOU SAY OH THIS IS WHAT'S GOING
ON WITH FACEBOOK ALLOWING PEOPLE
TO COME IN AND THEY CREATE THESE
THINGS BECOMING MORE OF A ISSUE.
IN THIS CASE, THEIR MOTTO SAYS
DON'T BE EVIL.
>> Greg: IT IS HYPOCRITICAL.
>> Juan: IN THIS AGE.
I AM SURPRISED AT YOU, GREG.
YOU HAVE BEEN HARD ON ARTIFICIAL
INTELLIGENCE SAYING THAT IT CAN
BE USED TO HURT US AS
HUMAN BEINGS.
NOW YOU ARE SAYING NO, JUST LET
ALL ARTIFICIAL INTELLIGENCE COME
ALL TECHNOLOGY FALL INTO THE
HANDS OF PEOPLE WHOSE JOB IT IS
TO KILL PEOPLE.
>> Greg: WHAT I AM SAYING IS
IF THIS HELPS MAKE WEAPONRY MORE
PRECISE ON THE BATTLEFIELD, YOU
WILL SAVE INNOCENT LIVES,
CIVILIANS.
WILL POOL TO HAVE THINGS LIKE
DRESDEN WHERE YOU HAVE TO BOMB
ENTIRE CITIES.
YOU HAVE A DRONE OUT IN FRONT OF
SOMEBODY'S WINDOW WAITING FOR
THAT TERRORIST AND WHEN THAT
PERSON GOES OUT, IT ZAPS IT.
>> Kimberly: LIKE A BUG
ZAPPER.
>> Kennedy: WE SAW UNDER
PRESIDENT OBAMA HOW MUCH HE
MISUSED DRONES AND TECHNOLOGY.
SPEAKING OF A REPUBLICAN OR
DEMOCRATIC PRESIDENT, IF
HILLARY CLINTON WERE PRESIDENT
WITH THESE GOOGLE EMPLOYEES
MANUFACTURING THE SAME THING.
>> Juan: THEY SIGNED A HUGE
LETTER, THOUSANDS OF THEM SIGNED
AT.
THEY ARE UPSET ABOUT FOR EXAMPLE